informations agressée par jour c'est
l'annonce choc de l'ordre national des
pharmaciens qui tentent d'alerter où ils
étaient venus soutenir l'OM et ils ont
été bousculés et violemment pris à parti
par des supporters corses la ministre
des Sports Amélie ou desa castéraira a
parlé d'un acte absolument un tolérable
ça montre vous voyez une espèce de
dérivée on a raison de ne pas s'y
habituer et donc j'attends que les
sanctions les plus
claires fortes reprises le ministre de
l'éducation nationale parlait la semaine
dernière d'un échec collectif d'une
tragédie pour ses proches pour
l'éducation nationale et pour le pays et
alors que la famille dénonçait un manque
de soutien du ministre celui-ci leur a
donné rendez-vous c'était aujourd'hui ça
me semble insuffisant
il y a des choses qui ont été dites mais
pas prêt au sérieux pour moi
pourquoi
une autre décision de justice qui était
très attendue par la famille du petit
Lucas 13 ans qui s'était donné la mort
en janvier dernier 4 adolescents bien
été reconnus coupables de harcèlement en
revanche le tribunal n'a pas reconnu de
liens de cause à effet entre le
harcèlement qu'il subissait et son
suicide je pense que rien n'est audible
rien n'est acceptable et chacun peut
comprendre la réaction des parents je ne
sais pas il faut encore je ne suis pas
non plus ministre d'éducation nationale
je suis convaincu que papendiaye a fait
tout le nécessaire et fera tout le
nécessaire au niveau de du dialogue on
n'a pas senti vraiment affecté par la
situation de notre fille maintenant on
attend au niveau des actes on l'invité
monsieur le ministre participé à la
marche blanche on espère qu'il viendra
qui viendra qui sera présent cet en
sauvagement et cette décibilisation
et la conséquence de l'effondrement de
l'autorité dans notre société
ce taxi parisien subit une tentative de
braquage le 23 mai dernier alors qu'il
circule sur le périphérique dans le nord
de la capitale avec à son port des
touristes chinois sur ces images on y
voit plusieurs sacs de luxe sur la
banquette arrière les touristes paniqués
ce sont quelques notes de réconfort pour
accompagner aujourd'hui une mère un père
et un frère dont le deuil s’étire depuis
plus de 3 ans un homme sur un scooter
revient au niveau du taxi
le conducteur refuse et percute le
voleur la vidéo a été tournée par Ridan
tong une influenceuse chinoise de 23 ans
qui l'a diffusé sur les réseaux sociaux
afin de dénoncer l'insécurité des
touristes dans la capitale française et
le procès de l'ex petite amie de China
s'est ouvert ce matin devant la cour
d'assises des mineurs de l'Oise le jeune
homme de 17 ans au moment des faits est
accusé d'avoir assassiné et brûlé vive
cette adolescente de 15 ans en 2019
suspecté de l'avoir mise enceinte avant
de la tuer pour laver son honneur jugé
aujourd'hui à huis clos il nie toujours
l'effet malgré sa présence avéré sur les
lieux du crime et des traces de brûlure
trois hommes soupçonnés d'avoir agressé
le petit neveu de Brigitte Macron son
jugés à partir d'aujourd'hui à Amiens le
procès s'est ouvert en début
d'après-midi pardon à 14h les accusés
sont âgés de 20-22 et 34 ans j'en ai
parcours de vie difficile très accidenté
le plus jeune est considéré comme
handicap handicapé en raison de son
illettrisme il n'a pas d'emploi il a
déjà été condamné pour viol sur mineur
le plus âgé lui et sous curatelle il est
le principal protagoniste dans l'affaire
trogneux il portait notamment un couteau
lors de l'agression enfin deux hommes de
20 et 35 ans étaient condamnés
aujourd'hui à des peines de 12 et 15
mois de prison ferme pour avoir agressé
le petit neveu de Brigitte Macron les
tensions se multiplient entre les armées
américaines et chinoises à proximité de
l'île de Taïwan une semaine après
l'incident aérien entre deux avions de
combat deux navires se sont retrouvés
très proches l'un de l'autre vous le
voyez un navire chinois à exécuter des
manœuvres à proximité d'un destroyer
américain du Japon pour journal ou des
étudiants réapprennent ta sourire après
la pandémie de covid regardez ces images
après avoir porté le masque pendant
plusieurs mois et bien beaucoup n'y
arrivent plus alors l'entreprise smile
education donne des cours à l'Institut
d'Art de Tokyo et c'est grâce à un
détecteur facial que sourire des
étudiants est évalué sur une autre de
100 et figurez-vous qu'une séance privée
coûte environ 50 euros la dernière
byeovic prend lui sa retraite définitive
et l'émotion était palpable hier à Milan
pour le dernier match du géant suédois
qui a même versé regarder cette petite
larme et oui au moment des adieux